[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the adam project the new
netflix original film this comes from
director sean levy and also very famous
producer sean levy who's done stranger
things free guy
much more stuff he's been around for a
while and he's teaming up again with
ryan reynolds producing this like they
did free guy and he's got a team of
writers on this film and it was
impressive because to me this script
right off the bat was really strong
especially with having so many writers
working on which usually is a red flag
but not the case here now like all ryan
reynolds projects you know i really
think a lot of you liking it or not
hinges on how much you like ryan
reynolds if he's your cup of tea or not
i've said in my previous reviews i'm a
huge ryan reynolds fan i am totally down
with his sarcasm his wit is great
improvising his humor it always hits me
and
i might be a big biased reason why i
actually really adored this film but i
could see it being polarizing again like
all ryan reynolds projects were
with a lot of comedy in general too like
will ferrell a lot depends on how much
you like the type of humor and that
person what's so great though is we have
this
surprise amazing performance from the
character of adam's younger self playing
the young ryan reynolds here walker
scoble who absolutely kills ryan
reynolds type of sarcasm is wit and just
the mannerisms it's down to a t i'm
pretty sure he's wearing contacts
because he has blue eyes in real life
and then he has those ryan reynolds dark
brown eyes here but he really transforms
into ryan reynolds as a kid does it so
well so it's so impressive for kid actor
but it's got such a great cast around
ryan reynolds we got jennifer garner
mark ruffalo zoe saldana who always
loves seeing and stuff she's so great
and it's amazing i saw a stat somewhere
in twitter that movie she's in just
constantly get high viewership so there
is something about people love but
there's actually a relief too to not see
her in heavy makeup like she is for
guardians of the galaxy or avatar where
she's cgi this is her in her full form
where i was just singing all the time i
want to see this more and katherine
keener as always plays a great villain
here so what works really well about
this film to me is the story right and
that
it has a clear-cut message in it and
that's said towards the end of the film
where we get this great scene where the
two atoms are talking to each other and
the younger adam's saying it's easier to
be angry than to be sad right this is
the whole message of the film and
there's a great line before that where
they're talking about his hate for his
father he's like you hate him because he
died you made yourself hate him so you
didn't miss him dad always had a catch
even if he was tired so
i thought all this was great there was
just certain scenes that really stuck
with me and they did a good job of like
the moment it almost felt like it was
getting too sappy at points it would hit
with some kind of
wittier mark by ryan reynolds or some
action so they they had a nice balance
of tone here and you knew this was
coming scenes like this because there
was really good scenes even just in the
beginning with jennifer garner and ryan
reynolds in the bar and he's talking to
his mom and they had a fun time just
playing around with the time travel in a
way where they didn't obsess about the
time travel itself that really isn't
something they were like oh we gotta get
the logic right it wasn't the point of
the film the time travel is just there
as a plot device to get things going to
where they need to be they actually just
had fun with these characters and again
the message and it was a good plot that
they were trying to destroy time travel
so that felt a little more fresh too but
even this scene it's portrayed so
beautifully by ryan reynolds here when
he's talking to his mom and ryan
reynolds really showing his acting chops
in this film especially dramatic acting
chops and
i love the message it had to here too
about him telling his former self
through all his regrets he's had in life
you know to be good to his mom that his
mom is suffering and that he tells the
mom to tell her son that she has this
sadness in her and that she is
struggling you don't have to be perfect
like all these themes were just clicking
so well in this film and they got their
pass by the end and it really paid off
all this setup with those kind of
moments because it really hit home when
young adam later on
clicks to him and he remembers somewhere
in his brain that his future self told
him to hug his mom extra tight i thought
that was really well done and i also
thought a lot of the action was really
well done here with
keeping it interesting and what really
stood out to me is chasing where they're
getting chased by mia the two atoms and
they're in they're flying and i love
that he stops the jet and then goes but
it had a nice
rhythm to it and it had stakes that were
interesting it wasn't just over
loaded with action here every action
scene was had a little story in it of
who was the target you know who they're
running from and it kept that suspense
up which i thought was really nice but
there was little humorous moments
that were so great and subtle like one
of my favorites was adam is with laura
here and she's meeting young adam for
the first time and she's basically
giving exposition for the film for us to
understand giving it to the older adam
but while she does that she goes here
make sure you eat something young adam
and she hands him a carrot and he just
mouths what the f i thought that was so
funny and it shows already that comic
timing that walker scoble has and how
good he is at it already and one of the
best humorous scenes is when mark
ruffalo comes into the picture and it's
just
always exciting when you see
a scene in film that you feel like
you've never seen before and that's
really here it really stood out was like
so brilliant to me where he's fighting
with the adult adam trying to be nice to
the younger adam and they're both
reacting to their dad at the same time
and he's like why did you grow up to be
an [ __ ] and then he's like i thought
you loved me and then the younger one
responds i do i thought that was just
great and it was great to see
the older adam talked to the younger
adam in front of the dad and how
differently they're trying to react to
him so cool and just again that
moments like this with mark ruffalo and
ryan reynolds just doing awesome with
the improvising clearly with some of the
comedic responses to each other they
probably took so many takes trying
different things they still brought in
again
nice heartwarming things touching things
to make those payoffs earn like the
scene where they're having the catch at
the end and they disappear was great and
that had to be earned by having moments
where
you know he's asking his dad to be a
father not just a scientist and again
like that picnic scene which really was
the best to me with the young adam
talking to the older adam you know about
not being mad anymore and it's just even
a heartbreaking moment when you see
young adam wants to tell his father so
bad that he dies i thought that was
great it's not spielberg level but it's
clearly inspired where you have
such good adventure here action but
a lot of heart and
i love the pace of this film too i
thought it constantly was moving it was
doing what it needed to do especially
for its target audience right that
someone wants just to escape but feel
warmth from it but also a lot of
laughing it was just your classic
feel-good blockbuster that really was
effective in what it was trying to do
now
only criticisms i might have is that
maybe the story line with zoe saldana's
character of lauren didn't get enough
time and then it makes me think maybe it
wasn't even needed you know i think
it is a nice touch and it's great to
always have her in a film but
you know it kind of just was there to
set up that big moment at the end where
he finds her again which was awesome but
i felt like maybe it was just adding
another thing they probably didn't even
need because they already had this
strong story with the dad and that you
know we really in the day to get much
time with laura now
you know maybe if there's a sequel it
will be more justified but again maybe
if you look at it a different way that
maybe that wasn't totally needed it was
still effective but definitely needed a
little more time there because i still
barely felt like i knew laura so maybe
the payoff didn't feel as strong and i
like with the villain of mia that they
gave her a scene to talk about how all
her life is this mission right with the
time travel and that she doesn't have a
life outside of it and she's talking to
her younger self but i don't know if you
know catherine keener did we really even
need to have the d aging effect or cgi i
don't know if that was completely
necessary just kind of let her look how
she is you know and i thought that maybe
her character could have used a little
more screen time too even just to get a
little more about her motivation of what
she does so she's not too
one-dimensional as a villain now i love
in this final battle scene we get
the tease about the lightsaber he has
adam and then the younger adam finally
gets to play with it and i love that
they do the superhero landing line a
shout out to deadpool obviously with
ryan reynolds that was cool i love kind
of anything ryan reynolds has that right
to break that fourth wall and kind of
step outside of the movie in our heads
and you can't go wrong with having
boston foreplay a long time playing
during that scene so good music choice
so overall i'm giving this film an 8.8
you know it's always hit or miss with
netflix films where they'll get a big
cast and it's a little disappointing
it's just not that good but this one
felt like there's a lot of passion put
into it love put into it and it was
really well done so
i definitely recommend it and i think
that
it is fun for adults and younger people
again maybe not kids because it's got
some dirty language in there but
overall i was totally satisfied with it
and i hope netflix brings more quality
film like this especially you know if
they're going to raise prices like
they've been doing recently that you got
to give us a little more higher content
quality on the film side of things
because they're usually known for good
television but we need more good netflix
films especially if these big stars you
know make it worth it use them in their
talents and this film does i think it
lets ryan reynolds just do his thing and
he was on point this time you know so
really really good film and i really
want to hear your guys thoughts on it
let me know did you guys like it did you
not like it
and please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my movie reviews
i also do tv reviews as well in
celebrity interviews you know check that
out and please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter tick tock and instagram
for more of me and i'll see you next
time